welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the guy in
lockdown that you have as much chance of
seeing as the Schneider cut just kidding
but not really this week we have two
massive new updates on the project and
it's very exciting news for fans of the
director throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down statements by
Justice League stunt coordinator Eunice
Hutt heart and Grace Randolph who have
both said they have inside news on the
project before we get into the story
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for a chance to win a copy of the Star
Wars Skywalker saga box set which we're
currently giving away to all subsets
drop a comment we're gonna be choosing a
winner at random on the 15th of April
and the set will be shipped out from
then so it's definitely something to
look forward to if you currently stuck
in doors anyway without the way thank
you for clicking the video now that's
getting to our Snider cut updates ok so
Grace Randolph posted a video on the
23rd of March that outlined some of the
things that she'd heard about the Snyder
cut as well as what she thought was
going to be happening on the project
I'll leave a full link in the
description to a video and play the clip
in just a bit but just a quick catch up
on grace in case you haven't checked out
a channel before she's been doing movie
reviews since long before I got into
YouTube and is built a huge following
for herself to you to her being a
die-hard DC fan I do you think she's a
very legitimate source and though she's
not right 100% of the time she's lasted
for so long on the platform because
she's bang on with a lot of things she
was even given a cameo in Zombieland too
so yeah she does have a lot of
connections in the industry and this is
why the information is more authentic
than others ok so just some context on
the clip in it grace talks about whether
Wonder Woman 1984 will move to streaming
in the wake of a report last week from
The Wrap she discusses how HBO max is
launching in May in the US only for the
meantime and next year in other
countries she discusses the flaws in
this and how it's unlikely that the
Snyder cut will release when the
platform does however she does say that
it may be used as a dangling carrot to
drive subscriptions she also talks about
how there are elements that Zack wishes
to change and finish before releasing
but not what these are or what could be
happening anyway here's the clip which
discusses things in more detail
as we've discussed before on Twitter
this is my first time discussing at
Nvidia HBO max had hoped to make the
Snyder cut part of its launch or at
least part of its launch announcements
like you would maybe you wouldn't get
the Snyder cut launch but it would be
coming very soon and that would inspire
people to sign up for the service but
I've heard again from my sources that
Snyder wants to shoot several new scenes
that require VFX work and of course now
they can't do that
so HBO max suddenly doesn't have that
caret either now yes a finished version
of the Snyder cut does exist he's put
out photos of it a handful of people
have seen it and they've loved it and I
can understand that some of you might be
like well again under the circumstances
just give me what you've got
but I mean I think that would be a
mistake from what I've heard of what he
wants to add it will mean the difference
between diehard fans having the
satisfaction of finally seeing it versus
piquing the interest of even the casual
fans and naysayers it's that cool he
really has some cool ideas for what he
wants to add to this and since he's
waited this long
I think he should hold off until he
could do it the way he wants to I mean
the Snyder cut has taken on like
mythological proportions at this point
it's a legend and you can imagine the
intense pressure to live up to that
legend and I think the additional stuff
that he has planned will allow him to do
that for sure trust me
so the Snyder cut I think for the time
being is off the board so there are two
things that we can take from this the
first being that the Snyder cut is
pretty much off the board in terms of
being released on HBO max when it drops
HBO max is launching in May and as we've
had no official word from either Warner
Brothers or people close to the project
then it's highly unlikely that it will
be dropping with it it's now almost a
month away and as I'm sure you can guess
CGI takes a lot longer than this to
fully finish HBO max is also going to be
exclusive to America for a long time and
therefore I don't think it's a smart
move to put it out when only a specific
part of the world can get it secondly
great also states that Zac is looking to
add new scenes and VFX to the work we do
know from the cryptic post at Schneider
Power recently that he was looking to
reshoot certain elements
movie this could potentially add things
and all in all it was going to be done
to complete his vision so I think due to
time constraints and the fact that
everything is shut down right now in
Hollywood we can safely say that the
project will not be releasing with the
new streaming service that being said it
also does seem likely that zach is still
working on things and recently on his
Fiero he posted an image of the five
heroes in the film we know that Superman
was going to be the sixth hero and Zach
did confirm in the comments that Green
Lantern would be the seventh so he is
clearly putting a lot of thought into
the project and I do believe that he
will be working on it anyway I blinked
the full video that grace dropped in the
comment section below so if you want to
see more of the ins and outs of that and
definitely go check it out after this
now as for the second story this comes
from the Justice League stunt
coordinator Eunice ho tart who recently
has been doing the rounds promoting Star
Wars the rise of Skywalker her heart was
also the stunt coordinator on that and
when conversation turned to the rumored
JJ Kurt things also naturally went to
the Snyder Kurt according to the stunt
woman she spoken with several people out
there that have seen the film and they
told her that it was absolutely amazing
Hut Hart spoke to website Screen Rant
and said the following yeah there's a
few questions about that and I'm sure
that I'm okay to say I officially know
people who've seen the Snyder cut and
said that it's absolutely amazing I do
believe that that's the movie we were
making Zack Snyder's version of the film
you know with the heartache of what
happened with his daughter he pulled out
and did the reshoots of it so the movie
took a slightly different turn so from
this we do know that they were indeed
heading in one direction and then the
reshoots completely changed the tone of
the film which in my opinion did leave
it feeling disjointed from the prior DC
films Man of Steel and PBS ho todd
further went on to say I watched the
cinema release of the film and a text
Zack to say what's this I'm hearing
about this Snyder cut I need to see it
he did promise me next time I'm in LA
that I'll go watch it so I will at some
point definitely go and watch the Snyder
cut and I have spoken to people who
actually said it's brilliant
they said it's absolutely golden so we
do know that the Snyder Kerr is complete
editing wise and that Zack has copies of
it it has long been said that the VFX on
the film are incomplete and that this is
the main thing holding up
but of course they are now looking at
reshoots the majority of stars on the
film including gal gadot and Ben Affleck
have come forth and said that they
support the release of the movie and we
did have an interview with Jason Momoa
that dropped last year in which he said
the following when discussing the
project
totally so is that partially why when we
spoke about a year ago some fans are
obsessed with the so called Snyder punch
of Justice League that didn't alternate
car yeah where are you I mean are you
what's your take on that I mean I you
know that's just one thing that it sucks
with our business where you just can't
speak your mind but yeah I brought up a
Snyder cut you're like yeah I need to
see that yeah absolutely but I have seen
so you see I've seen a static oh so so
what is that what does that mean because
the effects aren't done like you just
say you've seen his assemblage of
footage and alternate takes since that
or do you think he's I couldn't finish
you know the I don't know you tell me
he's he's finished I'm a listen man next
question do you think we'll ever see it
do you think the public will ever see it
at this point cuz it seems like it's
actually the groundswell has grown and
yes you know I'm obviously indebted to
Warner's in DC and you know I don't know
how they feel about it but I mean right
as a fan I'm very very happy that I got
to see it does that feel like a totally
different movie than the Justice League
that was released you okay
so there's clearly a lot of evidence
that the cut does exist and that Zack is
still highly invested in it however I
don't think that it will see release on
HBO max upon the services release and if
it did this would likely be a watered
down version due to the nature of the
special effects needing to be finished I
really hope we do get it but these
statements definitely fill me with a lot
of confidence that one day we will get
to see its release fans are clearly
desperate to watch it and I think that
if we don't it will always be something
that nags that die-hard DC fans like
myself hopefully when it's out we can
turn our attention to the next cut that
everyone wants to see which is of course
the butthole cut for cats I'm not
kidding there's a version of cats with
buttholes in that someone had the CGI in
and then CGI out one by one maybe one
day we'll be lucky enough to have
nightmares about that but till that time
I'd settle for the Schneider Cup being
dropped
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on these updates and whether
they've made you more or less excited
for the project comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out a breakdown of the full
story and the competition snide it
through that hinted towards their being
reshoots that kind of fells in one of
the big points in this video that I
didn't really want to repeat myself with
so definitely go check it out after this
you want to support the channel from as
little as ninety nine cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat us after
the show in the follow us at definition
whitey
or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully you see over there
very soon this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you